- This one was our most voted-on
question in the pre-chat.
People showed up early, racing
to get their questions in.
It comes from Sebastian.
"Are you doing the right thing
if you need motivation
for what you're doing?"
- That's a great question.
Do you know, um... Evan, I think,
the answer is always yes.
I kind of think it's almost,
like, and by the way, Evan,
I think you're the world's
favorite broadcaster,
that's the world's favorite
broadcaster, that's you.
You're that.
You're way ahead of
people like James Corden,
and stuff like that, who's an import.
Um, I just think, what
I need to say here is
it's almost like you need
to feed your inner self.
And I could think of analogies,
obviously around nutrition,
for health, exercise,
for fitness, well-being,
but I do think you need
to, um, as an entrepreneur
or business owner, you
need to create some people
who will give you
positivity, and people who
give you sort of challenge, uh,
and really good, critical,
constructive input.
And it allows you to refine your ideas.
And loads of ideas, and
I've done this, you know,
we came up with an idea in the 1990s,
and when we actually
launched it on the market
it looked materially different from what
our original idea was,
'cause we listened to people.
We listened to customers,
they gave us great input.
We never could imagine how
customers would have wanted
to consume our product, and
that allowed us to improve it.
So, I do think it's
important to get motivation,
'cause I do think you need
to feed positivity, optimism,
and also feed your idea,
'cause otherwise I think you could lose
the will to pursue your dreams.
So I definitely, yeah,
I would be an advocate
of motivation, positivity,
and I do kind of see it
as almost like a food
you need to be consuming
as an entrepreneur.
- Yeah, I agree, I think we
all have moments of doubt.
I don't think there's anybody
who never doubts themselves
and always, you know, is
fearless 100% of the time.
You need that in your life.
What I would would examine, Sebastian,
is if you are, I would
examine the motives.
Like, why do you want to do this?
Why is this business so important to you,
whatever this thing is
that you're trying to do,
why does it mean so much to you?
And if it comes down to that
you don't love it anymore,
or you're in it just
trying to make the money,
then the motivation won't help you.
You know, then it's time to
want to do something else
that you can get all fired up by.
But I think, like, for
me, it's a daily thing.
I wake up and I need to
use my morning routine
to get me fired up for the day, right?
Put on the music, do the
exercise in the morning,
you know, like, I have my morning routine
that gets me all set up,
and I need to do that
every day, 'cause I have a
great talk with Stephen Kelly,
guys, I'm like fired up for
the rest of the afternoon,
and then I'm going to wake up the next day
and I'm going to, like,
start from scratch again.
And so, I need that
consistently in my schedule.
But I think if you find
that you don't love
what you're doing anymore,
then it's time to move on
and find something else.
Stephen, you have a crazy morning routine,
you're up, and like,
you're running, and...
- Yeah, I love, I try and do, particularly
I've done a lot of traveling,
we do these kick-offs
around, see all our
colleagues, so we did, like,
one week down in Johannesburg,
from London to Pretoria,
up to Paris the next day, on the Tuesday.
I think then we went
down to Madrid Wednesday,
up to a place in the north
of England called Newcastle,
and then Friday we
finished up in Frankfurt.
So, I'll be honest, it
is full-on, it's intense,
it's like from 5 o'clock in the morning
til probably midnight, and if I don't try,
on most of these things, if I can,
sometimes it's just not possible,
but if I get up and do, like,
even a 20 or 30 minute run,
on that one it was great fun, actually,
'cause we invited, 'cause we'd
been doing loads of things
through the Sage Foundation, which is
the charitable arm of
Sage, and we did challenge
all our colleagues to
chase and beat the CEO.
So they all came out, you
know, down to Johannesburg,
we went on a run together,
with a load of colleagues.
Paris was, oh, mindblowing!
I got up, like, some crazy
time, like 5 o'clock,
and outside the hotel was, I don't know,
must have been 30, 40 colleagues,
and loads of these guys, amazing,
what sacrifice for them,
getting up even an hour early,
coming in from the suburbs, but we ran
from this hotel, it's like, probably,
about 5K, it's quite a long way,
uphill up to the amazing
church called Sacré-Couer,
it's on top of the hill in Paris,
and you were overlooking
the whole of Paris itself.
The sun started rising,
and it's magical, you know?
But, why do I do it?
Um, it lifts me, it gives me energy,
and there's loads of physical
evidence about endorphins
and all this sort of stuff.
So it is good, and I just
think, actually, Evan,
and I think, pfft, probably
one of my, sort of,
self-criticisms, I don't
know whether it's OCD or....
I'm pretty, sort of, extreme,
I love a routine, you know?
I kind of like a routine.
So the same routine sort of
helps me get into the zone
of coming in the office,
having energy, you know,
tackling good days and bad days, really.
Some days are good,
some days are less good.
But it gives me a good start to the day.
So, and I think, you know,
if you start the day well
then it's a great start
to the week, and literally
it gets you off to a right place.
And if you do, you know,
if you've had a weekend,
it's funny when you have weekends,
'cause you kind of reflect,
it's like holidays, vacations.
Let's talk about this.
Just a completely, thing
that came into my mind.
Loads of people on vacation
will think, "You know,
reassessing priorities, do
I really want to do this?
I've been at this business two years,
am I really going to break through?
Is it all too hard?
I'm sitting here drinking
tequila slammers in some
exotic resort in Hawaii, you know?"
Ugh! And little voices,
I find, on vacation,
really get into you, or
you can kind of turn it
and say, "Actually, it's
a great time to reflect,
and some of the things I'm
doing with the business
work in terms of my idea, but some of them
I could do differently."
And some people come back from
vacation hugely energized,
but also being able to
reflect from the outside in
on what wasn't going
well, and then come back
straight in with the energy to fix it.
So it is a good time to, if
you can do that, and I know
loads of people do things
like, honestly, mindfulness,
meditation, I think, you
know, I applaud those people,
'cause it just gives
you the space to think
and reflect on what's
working well and what's not,
and, you know, to reconnect
with your passion.
So I love that.
Hey, Evan, do you do any of those things
to help you get in the zone?
- Uh, so for vacations, I, uh,
I hate beach vacations.
I could do, maybe, like,
half a day at the beach
and then I'm out, then I
got to go see the city,
or I'm looking at the restaurant thinking,
"How could this business be better?"
Or, you know, analyzing the
people selling the floats.
And anyway, it's like, I,
uh, I need the stimulation.
In terms of a morning routine, though,
I wake up, like, I watch
the videos on my channel.
I made the channel, selfishly, for myself.
The famous entrepreneurs that
we profile was for myself,
because I wanted to be
around these great thinkers
and have some of their
mindset kind of seep into me.
And uh, it was a selfish pursuit
that I shared with others,
and they're enjoying it as well.
And I find that I need
that on a regular...
Look at my wall!
Like, I walk into this
room every day, right?
We've got people that I
look up to and I learn from
on my wall here, and it's all part,
I think everybody needs
to design an environment
and a schedule that gets
them fired up, you know?
Like, you may not know who this guys is,
or those people are,
like, it doesn't matter,
they mean something to me.
So it's not, like, copy mine
and put it up on your wall.
Find the people that inspire you.
I have these people
looking at me when I walk
into the office, it gets me fired up to go
and do the things that I
want to do, and kind of
think a little bit bigger and
get out of the comfort zone.
Um, so... now you're traveling
in your different city
every time we talk,
and, you know, but, uh,
for those of you who are not jet-setting
around the world, you know,
you could do something
in your home office, right?
Just have something up on the wall
that means something to you.
- Make it special for you,
just, I think it's great
what you do, Evan, and
I think, what I would
encourage us all to do
is kind of reconnect us
with our dream, and whether it's pictures,
or imagery, or prose,
you know, to connect us
with why we started our business,
and what our big idea could
do to change the world.
And, uh, if you come
and see that every day
I think that gives you power.